now mike yes
just like me you you used to read comics
when you were a kid right like i was a
big big into comics when i was a kid
yeah well i had some i had some really
good ones that probably would have been
worth a fortune now yeah i did too i i
you know i had a batman year one signed
by frank miller
signed by frank miller i had from when i
was like
maybe nine or ten i had
two of these special edition foil cover
spider-mans
okay that got ruined because we were
white trash and we loved saga we lived
in a bait
i think so and we lived in a basement
apartment uh because we were trash
and it flooded moisture well the the
water
thing broke and it ruined those comics
and i'm thinking about knows
those comics would have been like 27 28
years old foil covers
yeah they would have been worth some
cash well
mike the comic industry is
on life support and it's not going
anywhere obviously because
the comic movie industry is still huge
they're making them disney is making a
lot of money with marvel making the
comic movie so they're basically
letting comics stay alive and pumping
money into it that way they have stories
to pull from in the future so they can
make the movies
now somebody sent this to me and i'm
like why would somebody send this to me
and then i watched it and then i
realized why somebody sent this to me
oh you know what somebody just actually
told me about this
today today yes okay i just got sent
this before the show
get ready so when i grew up
let's say the marvel world this is the
stuff that i got to read like i got to
read that [ __ ] comic remember when
magneto ripped
wolverine's animation skull right
[ __ ]
dude it was right on the cover too right
wasn't that right i remember that yeah
ripped it right out i [ __ ] dark
knight
returns that was back when they knew how
to make a cover that made you want to
buy that comic
skeleton out i'll get this one yeah so
that's what you know we had these really
watchmen like there was some really
really good [ __ ] that we had when we
were kids that we could read and it was
it was like man this is cool [ __ ]
awesome bro
well mike let me introduce you to the
new cop yes can i just say before you
hit play of course
the new warriors wow that sounds cool
and badass it does right
warriors are new i can't wait to see
this cool and
badass new show i already seen it it's
not it's a comment it's not a show but
a comic but yeah it's like here we go my
name is daniel kibblesmith and i am the
throwing daniel kibble smith stupid name
that is the stupidest name i've ever
heard
i mean i've heard stupider fictional
names but that's the stupidest real-life
name i've ever heard in my life
let's check it out the writer of new
warriors number one
i got it it's a new new warriors she's a
new new audience interested in the new
world
by the way just stop with the hair you
know for as much [ __ ] as this audience
gives me for lacroix yeah nice try
trying to hang on to your hair
no this [ __ ] guy needs to let it go i
i shaved many years ago but that
nobody like this guy nobody's gonna look
at that head and go man i wanna
[ __ ] that guy just shave it warriors
number one
i got interested in the new warriors
later i remember seeing them on the
shelf when i was a kid
picking up comics in the 90s and just
feeling like they were too cool
for me what what
if the new warriors were too cool for
you every comic was too cool for you
yeah
literally just being in a comic book
store was too cool for you
like i was intimidated by you know
knight thrasher who had a blade coming
out of his wrist
you know nova was really buff and they
were all the edgy characters
for the 90s as the as the cover said no
they weren't
the edgy characters for the 90s were
like wolverine was an edgy character in
the 90s yeah one of these guys is flying
and he's leaving a trail of funfetti
birthday cake behind him it doesn't look
very badass
i thought were really interesting
characters because they occupy this
really cool space
they're forever young but they've now
been around
for 30 years my editors on the previous
books i've done like loki and black
panther versus deadpool
asked if i'd be interested in doing a
new warriors tie-in
that actually poses them as the
authority figures
in this conflict instead of the rebels
and i really liked
the attention of that so because the
new warriors are the authority figures
in this story they have to be mentoring
new new warriors who are under 21.
look at that wait okay come on that's
look at that
look at that killer yeah this guy i
haven't seen the other ones
i've only seen the two on the left those
are the ones that were sent to me
and i had to go like is this real oh it
is
and uh subject to the laws that
triggered the outlaw event
this new law is making it illegal to be
a vigilante under the age of 21.
the artist on new warriors number one is
luciano vecchio
he designs all of the new terrible art
also
very bad all right it's like tumblr i
mean it is
terrible terrible terrible art this
looks like the kind of art that's writ
that's drawn by people
on twitter who have the phrase
commissions open in their
twitter username new warriors and gave
them costumes that felt
as modern as the new warriors costumes
honestly i've seen emojis with more
depth
than these [ __ ] characters classic
and instantly
the writing so the first character that
we're introduced to is trailblazer
she's uh her home foster kid who is
volunteering
at a senior center when this mysterious
threat shows up and knight thrasher runs
to the rescue and because she helps him
she ends up in the crosshairs of this
new outlawed
law and she inherited from her
grandfather a magic
backpack oh come on man
what else did she get a [ __ ] insulin
pump [ __ ]
future door of the explorer here it's
just a magical magical backpack jesus
christ i mean like
you know wolverine had a an innate
ability to
not age and to heal at a ridiculous rate
and then they went wow we're going to
use that
and we're going to make this guy's
skeleton metal and give him [ __ ]
claws oh yeah and he's gonna smoke
cigars and be
be a dick to everybody and it was
awesome and now we're like she has a
magical backpack and diabetes
oh cool this new outlawed law and she
inherited from her grandfather a magic
backpack
of divine origin and also obesity she
also inherited that from him
type 1 diabetes the name trailblazer
because she's somebody who charges into
action
she knows that she can do some good with
this you know mysterious gift that she's
been given
screen time is a internet kid taken to
its sort of logical conclusion
as a youth he was exposed to his
grandfather's experimental internet gas
okay i'm done i'm tapping out i'm not
i'm not doing it no no that's my second
i've seen
listen i can't get over this nope nope
mike
no experimental internet gas
we're not even the good stuff yet nope
no i know the other ones pyramidal
internet gas holy [ __ ]
like i get it all you little lefties out
there you want to send a message right
but you realize that you're not good at
anything
experimental internet gas
oh my god you don't like experimental
internet what is internet gas
it's what powers the internet oh is that
what goes through the series of
it's a gas that goes through the series
of tubes now i understand the internet
dude this is like some early stan lee
level not even this
even because even stan lee's stuff
wasn't this corny this is some
cornball [ __ ] stanley would have
been like boy that's
really what about a radioactive spider
internet gas that sounds
stupid even i know that that's not how
the internet works
and i'm dead all right
it's just in screen time yeah to his
grandfather's experimental internet gas
and that has patched him permanently
into the world wide web the word screen
time is only ever
the worldwide world wide web surfing the
net is he
yes he's [ __ ] with this [ __ ] is
this guy for real
yes no dude i thought this was a joke
but i want you to
let me let me show you where this was
posted on marvel entertainment's
official youtube with 13 million
subscribers
ever used in a sort of restrictive
sense and because we're doing a story
about
teenage rebels a lot of the names
are about teens fighting against labels
that are put on them
so with screen time we liked the idea
that he has
infinite screen time snowflake and safe
space are
this is it this was the what was said to
me today and i was just like you gotta
be [ __ ] kidding me
he has that that [ __ ] thing under his
face
unironically these are the twins and
their names are very similar to screen
time it's this idea that these are
terms that get thrown around on the
internet that
they don't see as a derogatory
to take those words and kind of wear
them as badges of honor
i got a couple words you could wear as a
badge of honor buddy i can't say them
but i have a couple yeah i could suggest
a couple names for them
wait till he describes him because he
describes them almost sexually it's very
odd
by the way if this was in the 70s they
would have been like yeah screen time
and then we have two
superhero twins we call them chitlins
and collard greens
be on the new x-men and kind of wear
them as badges of honor
safe space is kind of a big burly sort
of stereotypical jock
because you know stereotypical jocks
were [ __ ] little shorty shorts and
two earrings and pink hair
yeah this is just a typical little
shorty short he looks exactly like uh
every guy in an 80s movie that would
dump everybody's lunch trays
he looks like a typical jock if every
typical jock with cisco from drew hill
yeah he's your typical jock like your
kid no he's not he's actually the black
guy from [ __ ] lambda lambda lambda
he can create force fields but he can
only trigger them
if he's protecting somebody else so he's
like a worse invisible woman because
wizard woman could make force fields
just whenever she wants but he can only
do it only when he's protecting people
okay but the other one's better and how
does how do his powers know
they just know mike the earrings it's
the earrings
hey he's a typical jock
typical chuck you remember
i remember the phoenix story so good
remember
dude it was that was a really good story
remember like there's so many things i
look back on you like man remember
remember the [ __ ] civil war storyline
oh yeah all this cool
[ __ ] and now it's just like this is safe
place in snowflake
and this guy is uh he's internet gas
what
like honestly if you pitch this to me
i'd go are you on [ __ ] drugs
get the [ __ ] out of my office get out
marbles are [ __ ] drugs everyone
[Laughter]
killed smash on drugs
if he's protecting somebody else
snowflake is non-binary
come on snowflake's not binary bro
remember when the old x-men stories was
wolverine just wanted to [ __ ] jean grey
this is gonna sell four copies and then
marvel's gonna go i don't know what's
the problem
i don't get it why are we losing money
because people want to see [ __ ] iron
man
crush and puss they want to see [ __ ]
captain america
they want to burn down puss they want to
see batman womanizing people yes
they want to see the joker literally
cutting people's throats like that
remember the killing joke he shot
barbara gordon in the spine
he murdered her he murdered robin with a
crowbar that's right he
favors gordon's wife and murder
like there was no like oh boy he really
[ __ ] him up no he just
murdered and this
is this is what is this
snowflake is non-binary and goes by they
them
snowflake has the power to generate
individual crystallized snowflake-shaped
shurikens
the okay i'm done i'm done i'm tapping
out
i'm tapping do me a favor guys mike you
need some internet gas
i got you submit you want some internet
guests the only way this would be fun
i guess the only way this segment would
be fun is if we could kidnap alan moore
and strap him down and make him watch us
could you imagine can you imagine alan
moore
than pitching this to alan moore and him
just being like
get out of my office right now i've got
snakes to worship
holy [ __ ] remember when the comedian
tried to silk spectra
in front of hooded justice by the way i
love that now thanks because of honest
movies trailers everybody says
silk spectra yeah still spec spectrum
justice and the other guy at least like
even in that right like you had gay
characters and stuff in the watchmen but
at least they were like
realistic cool you had the two closeted
guys i could never [ __ ] tell anybody
they were gay and they were still
[ __ ] on the dlc the lesbian chicks
yeah the lesbian chick but like this is
like
she makes little uh ninja stars that
look like snowflakes
sharokins sharokinas
i see little sherukens
the connotations of the word snowflake
in our culture right now
are something fragile and you're going
to take it back
and by the way let's not pretend like
stan lee didn't come up with some really
childly
simplistic ideas but at least they were
ideas we wanted to see
what if a guy turned into a spider and
you're like
you know what i'll [ __ ] give it a
look you know what i mean
what if a guy could heal non-stop and he
had a metal skeleton and claws
i'm in laser beams out of the eyes where
do you sign me up
and now we've gone to make a little
shariken set of snowflakes
okay this is culture right now
are something fragile and this is a
character who
is uh turning it into something sharp
snowflake soul shine says power rangers
are cooler than this trash
power rangers are the [ __ ] watchmen
compared to this you're right
and this is a character who is uh
turning it into something sharp
snowflake is the person who has the more
offensive power and safe space is the
person who has the more defensive power
is it this easy to be a writer at marvel
now yeah
zoe quinn's over there everybody's just
all you have to do is pander
and you can get a job there they they
have to understand that like sjws aren't
the ones buying comics right like it's
still
[ __ ] nerdy dudes that want to see big
tits and stuff yeah i think there's
too many people nowadays are paying too
much attention to twitter
i think that's really what it is and i
don't think they realize that
nobody's nobody even like i know people
that are kind of sjw-ish
who are gonna vomit when they see this
you know what i mean like i know people
that
that might be a little bit more
progressive and might be a little more
you know liberal about stuff and they're
gonna see this and go i have no interest
in that when's the new iron man coming
out remember when they murdered frank
castle's family in front of him
that's right that's right and then he
went out and he started
murdering villains to where the point
where the other [ __ ] heroes were like
dude you just can't be killing kill
crooked cops
mike you know what frank castle needs
little ice cube sharokins
ooh he would have saved his family
what if he had a force field that he
could put up only if his family was a
danger
it's really or if he had internet gas
what if he had internet gas it could
have stopped everybody how about we gas
the internet
holy [ __ ] man offensive power and safe
space is the person who's the more
defensive power
the idea was that they would mirror each
other and complement each other
e-negative is wait till you see b
have you seen b negative no i've only
seen i
literally the only thing that was sent
to me before the show was snowflake and
safe space
and i actually had to go this is a joke
right like this is your
i actually didn't even respond the first
time it was sent to me and then i got
the treatment of the comic book and i'm
like
wait a minute that thing you sent me
early that was real
e-negative is the goth kid
when he was a baby he got a
rogue life-saving blood transfusion that
we
assume from michael morbius and now he
has a very similar
look and can i be honest like this is
the sort of thing like
but do you know why he's called be
negative
because he's goth he's negative guy he's
not very did you watch him
charming and upbeat did you watch this
already bro childishly simplistic
but also like do you understand because
he's a vampire this is the kind of thing
and i'm not even gonna lie like if i had
if you had like a kid right
and he was in like second grade and he
made this
you'd go like wow that's very very cool
of you like you've got some talent there
kid
these are grown people writing this like
this is not the kind
again if you had like a third grade kid
and they were like dude look i drew all
these characters
this one's called this and this that
you'd go yeah that's
you know one day you're going to grow up
and you're going to actually experience
the world and you're going to have more
perspective to write something that's
not [ __ ]
but this guy's writing like a child this
is
childlike it's a very similar look
and very similar vampire powers be
negative also is obviously a pun
it's a bloods type which is great for a
vampire character
and it's also a proud ownership of the
idea of having a bad attitude
right now mike this guy does this guy
live in a locker
dude he should this is what happens when
you don't bully people yeah this
kibblesmith guy
reminds me the kind of guy that just
gets in the locker himself yeah i know
like
okay all right
he looks like she should have an
overcoat and hanging out with parker
lewis holy [ __ ] this
is bad i want the people who read our
new warriors
to feel all person of the excitements
that they felt uh if they read the 90s
one these ones look cool
yeah these are the 90s ones that's what
i mean like these these ones i'm saying
you can tell by the artwork but like
these
these guys look all right dude in the
middle looks cool
to have big colorful characters
personality clashes
uh romance a diverse cast which is
something that the new warriors titles
have always no this isn't diverse i said
this earlier than david but i'll say it
again
diverse cast was the x-men like that was
a diverse cast nobody got mad hey you
know
black storm girl [ __ ] canadian guy
x-men was one of the most diverse things
ever made but
it didn't do things under the banner of
diversity they weren't shoving [ __ ] down
your throat right it was like
wow look at all these people with
conflicting you know beliefs and
different backgrounds and all coming
together
to fight for the common good wow how
cool night crawler was a devil looking
guy that was a trad catholic like there
was a lot of i'd like to remind you
wolverine that storm is a strong black
woman
thank you all right got it thanks bub
i strived to make a priority every new
warriors comic has always
felt like a reflection of the the year
that it came out
and uh if this comic is a reflection of
the year that it's coming out we're
[ __ ] doomed
i don't think we're worried about being
dated i think we're way more interested
about it being now
well mike if it makes you feel any
better
the ratio is 6.8 000 down 1.3 up
nobody's gonna buy this and if you look
at the comments
oh my god so you have heroes whose
weaknesses are clapping and sensory
overload yeah that was that was fun
that was one good comment that was one
of ours but let's
let's let's go through some comments
what do you say let's hear the people
let's do top comments first
where's the super villain hate speech
when you need him uh next comment i'm
actually sad i can't dislike this twice
new superhero name lazy ass sister and
does nothing
that's how people at marvel are right
now uh
omega pie i can't wait for the new new
new warriors
soyboy with the power to transform into
prepubescent child
i bet when daniel accidentally bumps
into a woman on the subway he gets
irrationally excited and has to move to
another car
this is the worst thing i've come into
contact with all weekend
that's a great line holy [ __ ]
okay internet gas i can't i can't with
the stupidity this is amazing
uh marvel it's not too late to say this
was an april fool's day joke
is this out of season april fool's day
jokes this has to be you can't be
serious this can't be a thing
i want the people who read our new
warriors to feel the excitement they
felt with the 90s comic you sir have
failed horribly in your endeavor before
there was even a
single drop of ink on the page you
haven't even read the comics yourself in
your own words
this is why the comic industry is in a
death spiral and comic shops are closing
in mass
i like this one i bet your wife's
boyfriend isn't happy about this
you might not get to sleep in a bed
tonight
this is what happens when they people
think twitter represents society is what
you just said
disney we're going down fake marvel
don't worry mama i'm coming with you
uh at this point i don't know how
progressives
aren't completely embarrassed by their
side unbelievable
this is why anime and magna are utterly
destroying the
uh these western stuff and sales
popularity it's true
it's true uh and that's that is a big
factor of it you guys went so hard sjw
that a lot of people who probably would
have just
been content with comic books are now
going to anime
uh logan says experimental internet gas
gets
me every time this guy wrote imagine
having to explain grandpa's internet gas
to kevin feige
all right so get this his grandfather
had internet gas i'm sorry but who let
this guy back in the building
uh he does uh he goes by they them is
that the most hilarious thing i took
from this whole video
uh the writer looks exactly how we would
have imagined
this is great does marvel even know its
audience what kind of comic book geek is
interested in political correctness bs
she changed she charges into action
really slowly
stanley died for this
and their arch-nemesis of these brave
stunning heroes
are the problematics the troll the
boomer
the yahtzee the alt-rider and the leader
will be reality from south park
when do you think tumblr and twitter
when you think tumblr and twitter's your
whole demographic
kibblesmith safe spaces is a
stereotypical jock
has pink hair pink earrings and wears a
pink leotard
me did you even go to hotspot
kippel smith
yeah imagine having a kid and telling
you uh
it wants to be like snowflake or safe
space when it grows up
true oh wow the comments are still on i
figured they'd be shut off since the
comments section is a safe spaces
nemesis
[Laughter]
comment section really should be one of
the guys in the [ __ ] comic book
how many times do we have to teach you
this lesson old man
someone kept me oxygen i can't breathe
i'm laughing so hard
my god marvel just die already save us
all the misery
hey dad dad hey luke come over here i
mean
hold up just smoking some here yes
this one's great hey guys marvel just
came out with a new character called the
panderer